hi there my name is by my ship here I'm
a product manager on the Google Play
Store and today I want to talk to you
about what's new in Google Play app
discovery be together not the same this
is an Android campaign that's going on
right now it signifies the diversity of
the ecosystem the our users stem
from so many different countries speak
different languages have different
interests use different devices etc and
this particular diversity makes it both
a challenge and an opportunity for us to
build a great discovery experience so
I'm going to tell you a bit more about
it today but first want to quantify this
diversity we have over a billion users
they come from over 190 countries speak
63 languages and issue over 400 million
unique search terms each month I think
about that again these are 400 million
search terms different interests
different queries different needs
different questions the users are coming
to the play store to find apps that
could satisfy that they could satisfy so
that's really exciting to us and that
just signifies again the diversity of
the ecosystem with an ecosystem this
diverse how do you enable organic
discovery we think of it in three
buckets first is enabling discovery
through search search is one of the key
ways that users discover apps on Google
Play second is personalized in the
browser experience and finally it's
about enabling exploration which is
slightly different than personalization
as I'll get into later so let's talk
about search traditionally search is a
ranking problem it's about getting the
most relevant app at the top of the list
and over the past year we've invested
significant resources and making sure
that Google Play Store search is
incredibly relevant but we also took a
step back and thought about new ways to
serve results on Google Play and so we
came up with this new experience well
results the organic results are
clustered around topics and concepts
that are easily relatable to users and
this does two things first it helps
users narrow their intent faster they
can easily browse scroll up and down and
see which of those sub concepts are they
actually relevant to their query second
it helps users understand the range of
options and a range of apps that are
available on Google Play this experience
obviously only works well for queries
that are very broad areas that you can
actually break down into sub concepts so
look for us to continue to invest in
this and roll it out further from our
experiments we've seen that this
experience drives a greater total number
of install from more unique apps and
very importantly by more unique
developers all really really good things
for our ecosystem so let's talk about
personalizing the store one of the
insights we've had is that there is
really no average user when you have an
echo system like ours we have over a
billion users and they issue 400 million
search terms each month you really don't
have a prototypical user or interest you
can design for and in fact if you build
a product for the average you most
likely end up with a suboptimal
experience so we're invested a lot in
making sure that the Play Store is
relevant and highly personal to our
users we think of it as one user one
store and so if your user interested in
hiking and fitness you may see this play
store if you're someone is interested in
learning new languages and photography
you may see this one and most
importantly we've learned that
personalization really drives an
increase in installs and in fact doubles
the likelihood that a user will install
an app this is intuitive if you see
something that's relevant to you you're
more likely to install it but the
magnitude of the improvement is what's
really interesting here so as you build
your apps your experiences I recommend
looking at personalization as a way to
drive an increase in growth just like we
did here on the Play Store finally let's
touch on enabling exploration
exploration is different than
personalization
exploration tries to be a bit more
tangential if you've installed a number
of apps of this type I'm going to give
you a cue a few apps that are slightly
different and that's what we're trying
to grow and do more off on the Play
Store broaden users interests and help
them explore more over the past year
we've launched the developer pages these
are home pages for developers on the
Play Store and what this does is if a
user's browsing the developers ab
details page they will see a collection
of rich collection that when they click
on they go to this homepage in here they
see a featured app by the developer then
they see all of their apps that can then
navigate to one of those apps discover a
similar app and so on this continuous
cycle of discovery and browsing and and
pivots is really healthy for the product
and enables exploration we wanted to
invest in more next is google play for
families which we also launched this
year family is an important segment for
Google Play and offering them a
discovery experience that helps them
find apps is really really important to
us one of the neat experiences were
built is this character picker for
example if your kids are obsessed with
Superman or Dora you can easily come
here and see the icon for that
particular character probably the same
way they're dressed and find apps and
games and books and movies are relevant
to them very easily there's a really fun
discovery experience for parents finally
look for us to invest more in context
based discovery whether time based or
location based will look to aggregate
apps based on that context and serve
them up to users just at the right time
on the right place what it's living in
New York or a Mumbai or what is the
weekend or the evening will start
serving up more of these apps to our
users it's not a way again to drive
exploration of the store thank you so
much for listening in and states you
into the Google developer channel for
more content thank you
you